I hope this is working just trying this
out the stream is working I don't see I
don't see the chat unfortunately I
wonder if I can see the chat somewhere
right here yeah actually I do see the
chat okay
hello a couple of guys already in the
chat yeah it is working it seems right I
don't plan on I don't even have time to
do a real streaming here I just wanted
to check if it's working ok but it seems
to do um I didn't really put much work
into that the whole layout and and stuff
but it seems to be working all right
yeah i'm going to play like one game and
see what happens give me a three minute
game just to have a little bit of a
chest in this and this stream why do we
get a game i have to figure out how this
is working but shed is working in
started i said is that a good game first
game i get i get mr. ask my powers
really and he's playing the grope what
is he doing why is us my playing the
group yeah so we'll see what happens
here maybe get the night over to g6 ok
so well I probably go for trading of
this oh it's covering ok and I take this
knowledge from yeah I know it's his
Bishop is a dead piece that cannot be
right that cannot be right
so yeah I'm trying for b5 here Oh is he
going for an end game that was excellent
for black Wow yeah what excellent is a
strong word but I definitely like my
position here if you insist I'll take
this poor I absolutely will take the
palm so what happens here
it's put something on the C file his
nights are somewhat annoying still they
attack d5 pretty pretty well so I have
to make sure that nothing bad happens on
the C file I think I go back and go at
five night a4 I can play b6 that
shouldn't be an issue a success night a
for hmm that is slightly slightly
annoying okay it looks a bit funky but I
think it's so its own okay move
preparing that to be six yes the the
dishwasher is on this is was very
spontaneous decision to try this out I
found out that that i found out that
youtube streaming is working and i
wanted to test it out someday and now
I've got got some time and let's let's
check and it's like it's a good good
thing if you can if you can beat mr. as
my parish really here the vice president
of freedom if i'm not mistaken
yo that looks a little bit off here
night coming to c5 is annoying really is
yeah and now he's got this one and
nights seven is going to take
unfortunately it's a bit hey but not so
great maybe I have to go find healing am
a time is a little bit bit of a concern
and yeah the streaming via YouTube
always was impossible in recent years
and now it seems there's been some
change I don't know what exactly
happened there but now it works Jeff
well that's not ideal technique but it's
still a complete born hmm okay f6 is a
good square night f5 coming okay I have
to watch out for the time here hmm
that's bad check it overlooked this and
now King g7 I didn't see ya position is
ok but I've got 20 seconds check yeah I
know it's it's a problem check yeah he
managed to trick me what shame after he
got completely killed earlier check
I will definitely play this on time and
for certainly against as my parish
really with his history of each I need
and so on check check check check mate
ok managed he managed I was bad how
should have eaten him of course ok
anyway so um oh the best book to
introduce chest to a child between seven
and eleven hmm nope I don't really know
I don't really know I'm sorry yeah
moving to a new apartment this is
happening in one month exactly one month
it has to be set up not an easy they
have to be some some handymen doing some
stuff today we had the people in there
too um yeah what is it caught they read
a refresh the wiring in the kitchen the
electricity and well all kinds of stuff
yeah I'm going to play one or two more
games this is only meant to be as a
short test stream
yeah the delay is a lot lot less via if
I what I want to see game started good
master Dom it down David belches I'm
going for the three-minute gem when some
relaxed games my three million trading
also is crap I usually only play it for
the three million Messner's madness or
after beers so Jesus rating us by far
too low if I would put put some effort
in i would donate 2403 minute okay this
is all kind of reversed benoni and it
doesn't look like particularly bad bin
only i think i also played rather
quickly
yeah i'm shooting for some before
business they've got 38 spectators at
the moment considering that it was a non
announced stream I think this is a
pretty decent figure okay shooting for B
form probably going with f5 next but any
f5f forgives me the e4 square won't be
easy I'm not easily check my duty I
believe yeah i mean the stream was not
announced beforehand like it happens on
this and that day and so on the good
thing about doing it on youtube is is
that it it is so easily um done it's
it's the announcement is via youtube
it's not on a some kind of third party
platform and then complicated and stuff
it is quite easy to do and therefore for
me at least preferable to UM to twitch
yeah I've got the the dishwasher running
so this is a strange sound this is not
really related to the stream as I said
it was a very impromptu decision to do
this
cam trying to be quick here but he got
this night activated nights if I the
screen 87
yeah I've it dumb yes this is the kind
of move that looked possible I think I
have to cover him
could take the screen g4 and mate
actually made to follow yeah that gives
out a note that the stream is on it is
much easier that way than with twitch I
mean okay aunt which you can also
subscribe or it's not called subscriber
I think but you can get notified but
it's still a more complicated process
than just having it on on youtube as
well okay I think I try to go to seven
if possible Queen looks quite annoying
them that's probably not the not the end
of the world for him but looks quite
difficult night h4 maybe for Bishop g5
let's try that I didn't see that one
coming
maybe this one to go to drag queens on
the end game I thought isn't so bad
maybe I'm wrong yeah he's got a form hmm
before might come check
ha ha ha come on you've get absolutely
no time on the clock and I'm not worse
at all for the year
and night at 597 he can take on e2 at
the end set to said really true on a
joke Wow night tix takes on e seven and
then I cannot stop the porn Christ okay
talk about being lucky check black
forfeits on time okay got that one
that's a three-minute walk that's a
three minute pool
okay um no crazy house
hmm I don't know
game started okay guys crazy house and I
don't know what time that is actually
one minute and some increment we'll see
what happens one minute and three
seconds i think is this is okay he's got
a pawn that he can use but how are you
defending c7 now mr. qual o ok
that still looks like a relatively
normal game here he's got one point but
he's not using it somehow it looks like
normal chest where I'm better it Friday
induction ok I've got night and pawn now
this is as something that I have to take
into account hmm it's got porn and night
Queen has no squares here actually maybe
you can go is six this one hmm okay but
still the queen is a little bit short of
squares yep um what is what are the
rules of this you can probably you can
you can drop the Queen and so on with
check I with made here right I guess you
can we need the Queen a cell phone it
really is helpful um I Scott tonight and
porn
and lightly five hmm I just spotted that
he's got yet another night for nights Oh
didn't see that one coming the many
nights I extremely irritating hmm that's
not so easy okay they have it come on
this must be a decisive check now here
okay so porn here black resign and he
resigned okay yeah i got i got also
queen i probably could have played
something better here but i'm not a yeah
i don't i don't really know this game I
know how it works but didn't didn't have
any any experience there okay so i'm
shooting for some some more three-minute
games like one or two oh I'll kept this
at around 30 minutes it's just um it's
just a test stream anyway didn't do
anything fancy with it no big setup here
off the screen and so on
yeah don't don't get a game I having a
tons of games going on you've got
Gibraltar with all kinds of things
happening and we've got talet steel I
don't get a game yet it's kind of weird
no games gain started call Janeiro yeah
is that some kind of naughty would it
you never know I mean you know if you
know spanish but I don't okay the Trump
let's see what the drum can do oh it's
going to c5 and that's not good news
that's a sharp line and I have no idea
about it hmm I don't want to take the g5
hero having bishop edge for its going to
g5 I guess yeah anyway let's see that
three minute chest so some incorrect
sacrifices are probably probably okay
here there yeah I think Magnus will win
that event even though it seems that
he's not winning against who you found
today it was very draw at least and I
really thought that he would win that
game and basically wrap the whole thing
up but doesn't seem to be
yeah this is not a good position it
really isn't but it's also three minute
chess and whatever and that's not even a
good move Bishop takes a three I try for
Bishop f5 here oh he's provoking that
that's very surprising giving me a good
square there are only five why is that
okay I can go to age 3 i'm not sure
probably just back is ok
I'm 1395 now so he has to do something
about this and five maybe on 96 i'm
currently not watching any American TV
shows no not because I don't like them
there are many good ones but I sort of
um kind of i watched quite a bit a
couple of years ago but when i started
my HS business everything got kind of
yeah many things changed my whole way of
spending the day has changed and somehow
i don't fit in the times to to watch a
little bit of TV so I'm not currently
not know I would like to do a couple of
things they finish breaking bad for
example I only watched the first three
seasons and the start of the 4th I did
like Dexter yes i mean i didn't i didn't
watch I mean I felt I think like I
watched four seasons or so yeah what is
happening here my ping is fine his ping
is probably not fine yep so disconnected
dog ate the router or something like
that
yeah this is unfortunately ending in
some kind of wind by disconnection or
something like that good luck for fence
duty disconnection yes as announced yeah
I'll only be on for a couple of like 10
minutes or something like that not much
more it's just a test to see if it works
but it does work that's cool we got 40
spectators which is not bad on a Friday
afternoon without any announcements any
announcements before hand yeah a
position here is not particularly great
but well you can fight and I will very
likely cover Norwich as yes I'll do the
the most important events are usually
cover gain started lord of the board
maybe do this I wonder who that is the
Austrian flag Martin no power ok
okay maybe go a six never really
understood what this a4 a5 is about aha
93 to d5 that's any good okay
mmm just 90 f6 and try it maybe night on
g8 really doesn't it doesn't inspire so
much confidence the thing is if I take
well I think I'll just do that it takes
with infant efficient okay well yeah I'm
just fine I was thinking taking away the
night is more clever the porn is more
critical here black is just fine without
any any problems at all I mean maybe I
am anyway but here I don't see any
problems green age 5 or queen g6 coming
livestream match was assaulting us I
don't know if that's such a thrilling
idea
yes of course I pre-recorded the daily
blitz games it's uh I just record them
whenever halftime and they get released
every morning nine o'clock nine a.m.
german time now for more than two years
the three games a day ok so I was
threatening Bishop takes h3 and no I was
thinking Bishop g5 to just trade but
Bishop aged voice also okay let's trade
the the bad bishop here
where I store all the videos I mean
they're on youtube so i mean i have i
have actually have backups of all the
videos all the four thousand something
but just in case I don't know YouTube is
all of the Sun canceling my account of
stuff like that I want to make sure that
this doesn't happen but other than that
it's not a big idea
it's a very inconvenient position from
white it's also a little bit I mean I'm
heavily underrated with my rating here
off to one something check nice little
tactic i think i will play by play
regularly yeah i would be more like 2400
check white resigns okay so go to 2200
at least him yeah live stream functions
explain yeah this is German yeah this is
this is the default text I probably can
just change it to live stream by cheese
explain yeah save all that test stream
ok I'm going for like one more game then
I have to do some stuff
what is a fairly Rico sergeant how long
they got store before they are released
that's not completely it's not identical
sometimes it's like one or two days but
I've also prepared used for weeks when I
was on vacation I've done this quite a
bit i had a longer vacation lasts a year
like four to five weeks and i prepaid
used for six or seven weeks so it was a
was a lot of blitzing um who's the best
match on the internet I don't know
enemies on the stream I know that my
Beeman I don't think i have it
particularly i don't have anybody of the
of the other guys that i dislike I
really don't the hope they have kind of
normal relations to me okay so Cutlass
one and what is he doing here the thing
is if I can treat the light squared
Bishop oh that's a good move ok ok so i
will take it and now see that c5 is
coming ok i'm taking play on the d5
square yeah i'm john the following you
and and I we wanted to play a second
match but it didn't get to work and
currently it's a little bit difficult
because i'm happy about every free
minute as i have the upcoming move and
this is kind of stressful i have to
rearrange the chat window somewhere
because for the cheddar always have to
look on the right hand side yeah okay
here we have got a pretty typical
hanging porn situation how
imports situation I think I'm going to
UM I wonder I'm taking queen bee fives
also i go couldn't be five him the Queen
traders helpful yeah I'm John and me
blitzing is pretty even I think his bed
bullet I think he's his in in general
terms is somewhat stronger and the
somewhat stronger bullet player but he
also plays it a lot more yeah this is um
this is quite important you need
practice four-foot bullet shells and I
don't don't play it at all
yeah mr. catalyst what are you doing oh
wow isn't that losing material and that
looks very strange yeah if I go b3 I
don't see how he covers stuff d 5c 5 is
under so much pressure okay i think i'll
just take here you cannot take as the
assemblers hanging resins and resins
yeah well in the 3-minute pool if I'm
playing seriously I'll just win points
gained started plato's master roots but
its roots something who is that arco
alvia i have never heard of this person
ever cool yes the the youtube streams
will replace the twitch streams if there
are no complains or whatever i think it
works pretty pretty fine and one very
nice thing is that the announcements can
be made easily by our youtube ok one
more time this that's not Britney Spears
that's me and this line I always want to
ditch that line but at the end I'll keep
playing it I really have to say it's
some kind of unhealthy addiction I guess
okay so what happens here Oh
let's go here what are you doing miss
Surratt spritz whatever all right don't
get Bishop age six sandwich I would like
to do okay I'm trying for Safari it's
not so well prepared ok it's not
reacting to it at all
the check legs okay yeah everything that
sometimes the hand is actually making
the moment I only later recognized what
happens like yeah just blundered his
queen that was a pre move problem when
night sea floor was a pretty pretty
logical move actually ok anyway let's go
for one more game it was actually more
than I wanted to youtube has more like
than twitch I think it it has more like
ready for the chat but not for the video
the usual feelings for the video being
fine who Kim is the load of the board
what now Oh got some kind of began again
that's probably feeling some Austrians
oh maybe it's from Vienna oh let's it's
not a very very exciting line black it's
like equalizing instantly but ok his
position is of course super solid I have
no problems here but also not not much
to hope for ha ok it's trying for Bishop
b2 pressure on their porn f6 is not a
happy move h6 mmm age six I probably
should have thought about a little bit
it smells great
the video delay is just a couple of
seconds this is I can see the the stream
here so it's it's not a lot not sure
what the chat delay now I never use the
periscope yeah currently I don't have
much motivation to play on chess com um
if I want the best possible opponents I
go for the ICC and leeches is is a good
it's a good platform to play against
viewers or play the tournament so it's
not a lot of motivation to go for each
SF ohso com can i play the marshal
attack in my next three well technically
yes but I don't have any knowledge so
it's probably not particularly
successful endeavor did a wind during
the time i played poker I didn't track
it like um one on a very sophisticated
base I wasn't losing losing lots of
money thats that's what I know but I
don't think I'm um I don't think I'm
made a huge plus or something at that
and I definitely didn't do that but I
wasn't losing either there were a couple
of things I thought I did reasonably
well and some some I didn't I was I
think decent it's it and goes but not so
not so much in ring games my next league
game is on Sunday
and the gains have played so far in the
league were not very interesting so
there was just one game that is worth
making a video on and I couldn't didn't
get to that yet but i will make a video
on that game that it was reasonably
interesting check I'm actually
threatening media that's nice check ah
ok I didn't didn't see that more but
it's not a big deal i can take his pawn
see as well my king should be more
active why am I saying that actually his
King is as active as mine ha ok time
were actually quicker what the heck
that's not really great here
read probably lost here and will you
hold it I screw that up that was easy
just Luke a five
oh yeah it might be even better okay am
i'm not drawing now am I just blind
probably drawing i thought i could
easily lose this game game drunk okay
draw what the heck is that ok that's a
skype message guys I have to get going
but I'm happy that that that worked and
it's going to be I think a more regular
feature that I'm beat up the streaming
why YouTube it's much easier then twitch
and it is easily archived and so on so I
hoped you enjoyed that little show here
or 40 something minutes um yeah I have
to get going now I hope you enjoyed it
and it seemed to work alright thanks for
watching